[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans science orthez
notre nouvelle émission sur télé 78
aujourd'hui nous sommes au musée
d'archéologie nationale à saint germain
en laye et on reçoit court in jouissent
conservatrice et au patrimoine
ici oui bonjour bonjour alors qu'est ce
qu'on trouve dans cette exposition une
exposition en effet sur les fouilles
menées à la demande de napoléon iii à la
fois sur le territoire national pour
retrouver les traces de la guerre des
gaules est à la fois sur le palatin au
jardin farnese pour retrouver la trace
des palais des césar napoléon iii
s'identifiant à jules césar et voulant
s'inscrire dans la lignée auguste des
empereurs romains
alors vous allez trouver pour illustrer
justement ces missions qui sont lancés
sur l'ensemble du bassin méditerranéen
et sur notre territoire national vous
allez trouver des cartes des plans
d'époque du 19e siècle deuxième moitié
du 19e siècle
vous allez trouver également des
sculptures des sculptures prêtés par le
musée du louvre des moulages et surtout
vous avez trouvé des photographies des
photographies qui illustrent vraiment la
naissance de la photographie au service
de l'archéologie pour la première fois
on va pouvoir attester le réel c'est à
dire la réalité de ce terrain qui
produit les archives du sol et donc
c'est ces photos ont également le mérite
de pouvoir être véhiculée par leurs
tirages vont pouvoir être véhiculés sur
l'ensemble du territoire et ainsi
informer les populations qu'elles soient
savantes ou touristes informé de
l'évolution des découvertes faites à la
fois sur le palatin est à la fois sur
alésia alice un trend gergovie où
l'ensemble du territoire national alors
on va attendre un peu 20 ans parce qu'il
va falloir faire de la photo d'extérieur
et c'est compliqué la photo d'extérieur
puisque les outils les techniques
utilisées exige que le climat soit
constant et que les produits puissent en
effet sortir et être tributaire de ce
climat donc il faut plutôt attendre les
années 1800 fin des années 1850 début
des années 1860 pour que
la photographie deviennent vraiment
l'auxiliaire de l'archéologie fin des
années 1850 napoléon iii se repenche sur
les travaux de son nom que napoléon 1er
napoléon 1er qui lui même s'était déjà
intéressé vivement à la figure de jules
césar en tant qu homme de guerre
stratège émérite qui savait vraiment
mener ses légions sur le territoire donc
napoléon iii sur de cet héritage de
napoléon 1er va aller plus loin lui veut
démontrer par des preuves formelles
l'épreuve des fouilles a apporté par les
fouilles le génie de cette imperatore
romain qui a laissé vraiment son nom
dans l'histoire de l'antiquité donc à
travers la rédaction de l'histoire de
jules césar
il va ainsi apporter page après page
la preuve des dires de jules césar et
bien que nombre de collégiens déjà ou
lycéens ou traduit à travers les
commentaires de l'histoire de la guerre
des gaules où les commentaires de la
guerre civile
napoléon iii au musée d'archéologie
nationale souhaite vraiment créer un
musée à la gloire de jules césar ce
qu'il ne sera jamais puisque entre temps
interviendra la chute de l'empiré
mais napoléon iii voit dans la colonne
trajane situé sur le forum à rome
vraiment l'illustration de la grandeur
militaire de rome donc ils demandent à
au pape pie-ix l'autorisation de la
ferme où les et les moulages vont être
rapporté à paris dans un premier temps
puis à saint germain dans un deuxième
temps et ses moulages vont être source
d'inspiration source d'une iconographie
d'image temps pour la représentation du
légionnaire que la représentation des
armes de jet ces moulages vont être
soigneusement photographier en 1862 la
chance du musée de saint germain en laye
nez de conserver ses photographies nous
avons pu les les montées en un film
unique et pour la première fois les
visiteurs pourront voir sept longs
une longue campagne militaire en d'aci
par trajan sur un long bandeau de 400
mètres tel un film présenté dans la
chapelle du musée
donc cet exploit à voir quand des 19 dès
le 19 septembre et jusqu'au 3 janvier
en espérant qu'elle attirera et qu'elle
procurera autant plaisir qu'elle a
procuré aux commissaires de cette
exposition
merci beaucoup corinne suis pour ce
moment merci
et quant à nous on se retrouve bientôt
dans une nouvelle émission de sciences
orteils
[Musique]